plus pour le couler les gens sont pas
choqués les retours fin souvent les
commentaires il ya que des commentaires
positifs c'est plus justement la
démarche de tik tok qui trouvera un côté
un peu un peu tout pouvoir de bloquer un
son ou de supprimer une vidéo sans même
expliqué en face à moi c'est ce truc là
qui m'a gêné aussi c'est que n'y a pas
d'explication c'est notre coupe le son
est en couple et en plus ça a été sur la
seule vidéo où je suis accompagné d'un
demain germain quelqu'un qui est un vrai
handicap et qui est alors je vais on va
leur montrer la vidéo dartus et je le
dis à chaque fois ça fait des années
qu'on en parle dans cette émission on a
fait des émissions spéciales on en a
fait avec la ministre handicap chili et
les personnes qui ont un handicap elle
voulait comme les autres seul van et
comme les hauts et surtout ils font des
vannes mais bien sur papier et bien sûr
et puis j'étais moi je connais très bien
le milieu du handicap et ils font des
vins que même en choisissait pas faire
et donc vraiment au contraire c'est bon
on veut on veut les considérer comme des
gens normaux et on dit et on les met
dans une case où on n'a pas le droit d'y
aller tu disais on les considère pas
comme des gens normaux et jeudi les gens
moi franchement j'ai aussi côtoyé
beaucoup de personnes handicapées parce
que voilà où il savait voilà j'ai
beaucoup de choses à nice recherche
j'adore voilà je pense pas vraiment pour
cette cause pour que cet investissement
n'est pas un handicap être ministre
nommé arthur en fait à chaque fois ils
détestent canton il déteste justement
tout va les voir et qu'on leur parle
comme ça
c'est le sony sa route il s'arrête
téléthon c'est ce truc de mai j'adore le
téléthon je trouve ça très bien ce
qu'ils font pour apporter de l'argent et
tout mais je trouve que l'image doit
quand même changé c'est pas des chiots
sait pas où se marient même le seriez
bien sûr il si on revient sur vannes ils
ont envie de se marrer c'est une fête
pour eux ils ont envie de voilà et et
regardez le sketch a posé problème
[Musique]
l'accord lors
j'étais tout cela est positif pour moi
c'est
trop
toucher deux mots que moi je suis
déçu car les charges d'une personne qui
me suis moi même en situation de
handicap et je bosse avec des enfants en
situation de handicap je soutiens
fortement artus nous sommes les premiers
à rire des sketches sommes dans une
société où l'on confond humour noir et
méchanceté gratuite il faut savoir se
détacher et arrêter de prendre tout au
premier degré c'est sébastien cazaubon
des landes qui m'angoisse à accompagnant
d'élèves en situation de handicap et il
soutient artus et le t-rex c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable et moi
la question que je me pose c'est qu'ils
sont ces personnes chez tic toc ou sur
les autres sociaux qui décident de ce
qui est drôle ou pas de ce qui doit
censurer ou pas je te vois plein de
choses choquantes comme cyril l'a dit la
rue c'est son métier en plus vous faites
pour la bonne cause que vous avez versé
de l'argent à des associations que j'ai
créé le tictoc que pour ça c'est pour ça
que ça va un peu ça donc il essaie tout
un autre moyen mais je crois que c'est
des animaux c'était n'importe qui
mais d'ailleurs j'étais assez surpris
pour être tout à fait honnête au départ
quand j'ai démarré le truc j'ai été
assez surpris de des retours qui étaient
au contraire positif et je me suis parce
que c'est une plateforme va pas se
mentir où la moyenne d'âge est quand
même très jeune je me suis dit je vais
me prendre un saut de trucs j'écoute je
tente je mets la main comme ça plus voir
si je me la fais bouffer ou pas je me la
suis pas fait bouffer tout ça s'est
super bien passé machin et puis là il ya
ce truc là en plus sur cette seule vidéo
ou où je suis accompagné salaire je peux
pas être plus valide et que donc en
cause les mois je les prie encore plus
en mode en fait ce que vous censurez
c'est lui c'est pas moi puisque sylvain
ghsr 40 vidéos avant vous avez passé
s'arrêtent et là je fais une vidéo avec
avec benjamin qui est vraiment
rhizomique et vous censurez donc c'est
absurde en fait